[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo nous sommes heureuses de
vous retrouver pour faire ensemble tour
de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire de la semaine est avec moi
pour présenter cette émission tam tran
huy bonjour times bonjour brigitte est
notre invité philippe bas bonjour
philippe bas les merci d'être avec nous
et cette âme qui brosse votre portrait
philippe bas vous êtes né à paris mais
vous êtes sénateur de la manche normand
par votre famille mais élu depuis près
de 15 ans chiraquien historique vous
avez été son secrétaire général à
l'elysée avant d'être nommé ministre
pendant deux ans notamment ministre de
la santé ça va nous intéresser
alors est-ce les eaux froides de la
manche qui vous ont permis de garder
votre flegme tout british lors de la
commission denquête benalla vous avez
alors cuisiner mais sur un ton urbain
l'ex chargé de mission de l'elysée ce
feuilleton vous a valu une notoriété
dans des sphères que vous n'imaginiez
certainement pas regardez par exemple ce
magnifique photo montage issu du forum
jeuxvideo.com qui vous a représenté en
jedi à rien que ça
lorsque vous avez apprécié cette
notoriété ou est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est un petit peu réducteur pour votre
carrière
j'ai fait beaucoup d'autres choses
évidemment
et j'ai apprécié que les français
s'intéressent à notre travail
j'ai apprécié que les français comptent
sur nous pour établir la vérité je pense
qu'on a réussi à le faire et ça prouve
que le contrôle parlementaire c'est
important dans une démocratie
voyons à présent philippe bas le
sommaire de cette émission et le projet
de loi retraites
enlisé à l'assemblée nationale les
tensions entre majorité et opposition de
gauche se multiplient dans l'hémicycle
où plane l'ombre du 49-3 l'union
politique face à la menace du
coronavirus les présidents de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat les
chefs des groupes parlementaires et des
partis se sont rassemblés à matignon
jeudi alors que l'épidémie se propage
gérard larcher appelle à un débat dans
l'hémicycle du sénat
enfin les sénateurs veulent renforcer le
suivi des condamnés pour terrorisme à
leur sortie de prison
dans un rapport cette semaine la chambre
road adresse
aussi un satisfecit à la loi
antiterroriste de 2017
et pour commencer et bien on va
s'intéresser à la réforme des retraites
dont l'examen se poursuit à l'assemblée
[Musique]
à l'assemblée où les esprits
s'échauffent sur le projet de loi
retraites cette semaine a été marquée
par de fortes tensions la majorité
critiquent toujours l'obstruction des
insoumis et des communistes jean
numérique à des personnes qui étaient
qui était présente et qui était
absolument ravi c'est des jeunes qui
faisaient un service civique qui avait
reçu eux mêmes une formation qui tu
avais un bon niveau en numérique et qui
faisait de la formation aux personnes
qui étaient présentes
donc il y à aussi donc un travail
d'inclusion numérique qui est fait aussi
dans les français glisse donc c'est
quelque chose qui est très important et
quelqu'un me parlait tout à l'heure des
des écrivains publics
mais au fond les agents d'accueil dans
les français service etc les écrivains
publics d'aujourd'hui si je puis dire
c'est à dire c'est les gens qui doivent
être aussi capable d'aider ceux qui sont
loin du numérique et d'internet
alors je crois que j'ai aidé quoi
les classes en milieu rural ça existe
déjà les dédoublements des classes en
milieu rural
il est parti un mail et la voilà voilà
voilà cher jacques ça existe déjà
peut-être pas assez et c'est ça que vous
dites est dans le quartier mais c'est
dans l'agenda rural c'est un des points
de l'agenda rural voilà alors est-ce que
dino fabien et yolaine sont encore
frustré ou et et laurence alors
alors monsieur cinieri vous avez la
parole allez dire à pied merci maman
présente même la ministre effectivement
les maisons de france services
labellisés c'est un plus mais il faut
savoir que ça va passer un petit peu les
msa paix et dans le cadre de la
labellisation
effectivement certaines collectivités
n'ose pas investir trop puisque ils ont
déjà budget d'investissement qui est
serré et par nous et fait pas de terre
au niveau des deux des aides de l'état
nous donne au département vu le nombre
de d'investissement quitte qui sont à
réaliser dans les communes on se
retrouve avec des deux terres qui sont à
peu près à 20% du montant donc dû de
l'investissement et c'est peut-être pour
ça aussi qu'une qu'ils sont non
labellisés certains parce que
effectivement je vous comprends bien que
me l'aspect confidentiel au sein d'un
bâtiment
ce qu'il dit c'est ce qu'il faut souvent
nécessaire
bon sur toi après après les fermetures
s'ils voulaient des bureaux de poste de
trésorerie on a vraiment besoin nous de
deux maisons de frein service mais
financée à hauteur peu plus prudent
davantage que celles qu'on a aujourd'hui
merci même de courson je suis présidente
de commission madame de course on vous
avait parlé alors oui merci
moi je me réjouis beaucoup de ce
foisonnement de la maison france service
parce que c'est vraiment une bouffée
d'oxygène pour notamment pour la réalité
et justement on a on a beaucoup un
problème de non recours de nos
concitoyens des tas de choses auxquelles
ne vont pas donc moi je vois dit est ce
qu'aujourd'hui madame la ministre est ce
que vous pensez qu'il va y avoir une
campagne pour inciter les gens à aller
vers ces maisons seront en service pour
les faire connaître vraiment massivement
parce que je vois que ça serait vraiment
très important merci fabien di filippo
merci la présidente
nous sommes là la ministre juste de
remarques hamouma ma question la
première sur la detr des s'il comprenait
bien pour nous que l'argent qui va sur
les projets maison france service qui se
substitueront à des services publics
gérés par l'état existant bien c'est de
l'argent qui n'ira pas sur d'autres
projets d'investissement dans quelque
part quand même un peu perdus pour nos
pour nos collectivités
la question je souhaitais vous posez eu
égard au redécoupage et aux cantons
qu'on peut avoir désormais qu'ils sont
des cantons xxl j'en ai un qui fait
quasiment 1500 kilomètres carrés dans ma
circonscription donc une une ruralité
assez assez profondes ce qui pourrait
pas y avoir des critères qui se
détermine plus tôt en temps de trajet ou
en kilomètres pour l'accès aux services
publics plutôt que sur des sur des
cantons parce que effectivement la
question qui se pose chez nous au delà
du canton c'est celle de l'éloignement
réellement des services publics merci
laurence meyer méhaignerie j'ai une
petite question complémentaire 1 amiens
ministre est-ce qu'on peut envisager
alors peut-être pas 2020 et 2021 mais à
terme
déconcentré en tout cas la décision pour
que le maillage territorial soit le plus
proche
non mais au niveau des préfets genton
voilà que que les décisions de
localisation maison francs service lot
complet et tout ce qui s'ensuit puisse
être envisagée plus tard
à terme en tout cas au niveau le plus
déconcentré possible et enfin dernière
question marge aurait marjolaine mais
niemi le faire merci c'était pour
rebondir ce que vous aviez dit madame la
ministre sur la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments c'est vrai que de conduire
le débat de manière approfondie en
échangeant des arguments et je crois que
c'est ça la bonne image mais c'est aussi
parce qu'il ya pas le 49-3 au sénat
qu'il n'ya peut-être pas l'obstruction
en face non non je ne crois pas que ce
soit la raison je crois que la vraie
raison c'est que le sénat est issu des
territoires et que au fond les gens qui
choisissent les sénateurs au nom des
français c'est-à-dire leurs élus les
élus municipaux
ce sont des gens à qui on ne la fait pas
on peut pas leur raconter d'histoires on
est réaliste pragmatique et on a
l'habitude de la gestion des affaires
publiques
parce qu'il n'y a pratiquement pas un
seul sénateur qui n'est pas été maire
vice président de son conseil
départemental président de son conseil
régional et cette expérience qui fait
que le sénat de la république il est il
est ancré dans la vie réelle fait que au
sénat vous avez une approche qui n'est
pas polémique
l'exécutif commence à lâcher du lest il
ya quand même eu des petites avancées
dans l'examen du texte notamment sur la
question des avocats la majorité a voté
mercredi un dispositif de solidarité
pour les petits cabinets d'avocats ce
que ça vous l'approuvez vous le saluer
écoutez je ne veux pas m'inscrire dans
cette réforme car je crois qu'elle est
mauvaise
fumant naissance à des formes très
décevante les avocats mêmes ne sont pas
satisfaits des solutions qui leur sont
proposés mais ce que je remarque c'est
qu'on traite les unes derrière les
autres toutes les professions quand leur
fait des concessions qu'une partie de
ces concessions sont des concessions
très coûteuse
regardez pour les enseignants les
policiers qui peuvent se justifier
d'ailleurs pour d'autres raisons que les
retraites parce que c'est vrai que nos
enseignants ne sont pas assez rémunérés
par rapport à ceux des pays voisins mais
on voit que l'on déverse des flots
d'argent public comme on l'a fait pour
les gilet jaune et si bien que
aujourd'hui la cour des comptes nous dit
baye les finances publiques de la france
ne sont pas tenues et les déficits
publics
réduisent pas alors quand on voit que va
y avoir jusqu'à 15 milliards de déficit
en 2025 pour les retraites et qu'on est
en train de dépenser des flots d'argent
public pour faire passer une mauvaise
réforme avec l'utilisation de moyens qui
sont des moyens de force du gouvernement
alors je dis mais vraiment reprenons
notre souffle notre sérénité et essayons
de faire fonctionner notre démocratie
convenablement en essayant de résoudre
des problèmes réels et non pas de faire
des réformes pour résoudre des problèmes
allaient n'existe complètement réécrire
le texte au sénat
nous sommes en train d'y travailler la
commission des affaires sociales du
sénat mon collègue rené paul savary se
sont mis au travail ne ferons des
propositions qui seront des propositions
permettant d'assurer l'équilibré
financier des retraites car c'est le
service que nous devons rendre aux
français on poursuit avec vous philippe
bail avec l'épidémie de coronavirus et
le quasi consensus politique autour de
la gestion de la crise par l'exécutif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une image rare les présidents de
l'assemblée du sénat mais aussi les
chefs des groupes politiques et des
parties ont été convoquées jeudi à
matignon pour faire le point sur
l'évolution de la menace
à l'exception de marine le pen le
consensus règne dans la gestion de crise
nathalie gloire il n'est pas nécessaire
d'ajouter à la crise un climat de
psychose avons le devoir de nous
préparer au pire et en la matière un
principe de précaution s'impose
merci de nous communiquer votre plan
d'action pour assurer la santé des
français
les oppositions appel à plus de
communication plus de transparence
ils s'inquiètent d'un possible manque de
préparation de la france face aux
coronavirus le premier ministre edouard
philippe a donc décidé de réunir les
chefs de groupes parlementaires mais
aussi les chefs de partis autour d'une
table objectif l'unité nationale sur ce
sujet le calme la mesure le bon sens ce
sont des vertus que nous avons intérêt à
cultiver de façon collective
il nous appartient ensemble
gouvernements élus nationaux et locaux
média experts de santé publics
d'accompagner nos concitoyens pour
assurer leur information et leur
protection
pour répondre à toutes les questions
qu'ils se posent sans jamais jouer sur
les peurs les chefs d'opposition sont
ressortis de cette réunion convaincu et
se montre solidaire du gouvernement il
faut qu'une unité nationale il faut tout
simplement que tout le monde soit
mobilisé et puis surtout il faut
apporter des réponses des attentes et
notamment sur le terrain et partout dans
le département
on ferait pas de ce sujet une polémique
et de la politique politicienne si on a
besoin de notre aide
face au péril on sera là sur ce sujet là
le corps d'un virus n'est ni de gauche
ni de droite ni du centre
c'est un défi qui nous est
collectivement lancé et dans ce cadre
nous devons avoir une réponse collective
avec le gouvernement
seule marine le pen fait part de ces
divergences à la sortie de la réunion
elle se toujours une fermeture des
frontières je ne venais pas chercher des
éléments pour me rassurer
j'ai juste constater que nous avions un
désaccord et il me semble que quelle que
soit la situation des limitations aux
frontières ne s'effectueront pas à
l'issue de cette réunion edouard
philippe a évoqué une probable épidémie
en france
il appelle donc à la mobilisation et au
calme philippe bas gérard larcher a
demandé à ce que se tienne un débat au
sénat sur le coronavirus est ce que vous
le souhaitez aussi pièces que vous avez
des informations sur un quand il
pourrait se tenir
bien sûr que je le souhaite c'est
d'ailleurs dans la gestion de crises
sanitaires un élément essentiel informé
être transparents dire la vérité c'est
la vérité qui rassure même quand cette
vérité comporte des éléments qui sont en
soi inquiétant mais si en plus les
pouvoirs publics n'étaient pas
transparent alors tout et son contraire
pourrait se dire
et au lieu d'avoir du sang froid pour
gérer rationnellement efficacement
objectivement de manière impartiale
le coup validé ni transparent pour
l'instant pas bons on serait en grande
difficulté et je crois que le
gouvernement comme ses prédécesseurs
d'ailleurs gère cette crise
en informant les français au fur et à
mesure est ce qui est important pour moi
c'est qu'on a en france un dispositif de
vigilance on appelle comme ça de
sécurité sanitaire de très haut niveau
vous savez on n'a pas attendu le
coronavirus pour mettre en place ce
dispositif d'ailleurs si on l'avait
attendu on serait aujourd'hui dans une
situation épouvantable c'est en
permanence que quand il y a des lam
horse de contagion juste toute la chaîne
sanitaire du médecin de l'hôpital aux
directeurs des agences régionales de
santé jusqu'aux ministres sont informés
quand j'étais ministre de la santé
il ya eu des cas de méningite dans une
école
j'ai été le jour même informé ça marche
et donc je pense que ça c'est important
que les français le sachent
nous avons une administration de la
santé qui est aujourd'hui une
administration de la sécurité sadik et
qu'est-ce que vous qui sait
l'iba de l'initiative qu'a prises le
premier ministre de réunir l'ensemble a
prise dans l' assemblée sénat
des partis politiques et les
responsables des groupes parlementaires
à matignon on peut pas faire de
politique sur un sujet comme celui là
les gouvernements font ça dans des
crises beaucoup plus grave que le
coronavirus ça a été le cas par exemple
en matière de terrorisme où il fallait
que les français s'unissent gardent leur
sang-froid leur calme et que leurs
représentants jouent le jeu de l'unité
nationale elle va durer cette unité
nadja si vous voulez dans votre parti il
y en a qui ont commencé par tirer a
notamment les élus des alpes-maritimes
nous sommes actuellement dans une
période qui n'est pas encore une période
d'épidémie elle peut venir
il faut à la fois il faut dire la vérité
encore une fois c'est à dire que ce
virus
c'est un virus fortement contagieux mais
c'est un virus dont l'intensité
relatives à d'autres virus n'est pas
très forte
vous voyez que en chine
l'épidémie grâce à des mesures
d'autorité très fortes qui ont été
prises là bas semble être en train sans
titre 2-2 de rebaisser dans un pays d'un
milliard 500 millions d'habitants il y a
eu malheureusement plusieurs milliers de
morts mais j'oserais dire seulement
quelques milliers de morts savez vous
que en france la grippe la grippe à
laquelle vous êtes habitués elle fait
chaque année dix mille morts
donc si vous voulez je pense que les
choses actuellement il faut continuer à
être en vigilance sont sous contrôle
une épidémie peut se développer mais
tout est en place pour la contrôler nos
rêves à lui faire protéger les personnes
vulnérables
je vois les personnes accueillies dans
nos maisons de retraite médicalisées les
personnes handicapées des maisons
d'accueil spécialisées des foyers
d'accueil médicalisés les personnes
âgées vulnérables chez elle il y à des
précautions qui sont prises d'autant que
philippe bas il ya eu 10
audition a mené par la commission des
affaires sociales au sénat et
l'épidémiologiste arnaud fontanet est
lui resté très prudent sur la
possibilité de trouver un vaccin au
virus
écoutez je vous fait réagir le
calendrier pour nous c'est typiquement
18 mois pour les premiers essais je sais
qu'il ya des équipes qui dans le
contexte de l'urgence vont probablement
aller plus vite de que ce soit en chine
ou ailleurs dans le monde
après je vous demande d'être là dessus
assez prudents parce que notre
expérience avec les vaccins
c'est que il ya beaucoup de maladies
pour lesquelles malheureusement on n'a
pas réussi à mettre à avoir un vaccin
efficace et je rappelle que pour le
maire ce le syndrome de kanan virus qui
donc c'est plus dans les pays du golfe
ça fait six ans qui cherche un vaccin
qui n'ont pas encore réussi à mettre au
point
vous l'avez entendu un philippe bas
parole d'expert on ne va pas forcément
trouvé un vaccin est ce que ça quand
même ça vous inquiète
on va trouver peut-être un vaccin et ça
m réconforte mais ce n'est pas du tout
sûr mais si vous voulez au moment où on
va avoir trouvé le vaccin l'épidémie
aura très probablement disparu parce que
c'est aussi une course contre la montre
ces épidémies ont une forte saisonnalité
donc on peut espérer que tout semaine de
gagner nous permet de voir le bout du
tunnel
donc oui heureusement on a la
possibilité de découvrir avec ça pas la
certitude mais ce vaccin va arriver
alors que peut-être il y aura un autre
virus qui sera apparu quelque part sur
notre planète
hier il ya eu un échange assez vif entre
le président de la république et des
responsables de l'hôpital de la
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière à
paris
est ce que vous trouvez qu'il ya
suffisamment de moyens qui sont mis dans
l'hôpital depuis 2010 est sachant que
cette crise elle dure depuis longtemps
maintenant et ça je crois que c'est une
question tout à fait essentiel en
réalité je disais tout à l'heure on a
construit notre système de protection
contre les épidémies pierre à pierre ça
fonctionne ya une vigilance mais le
système de soins lui mais il est dans
une situation
ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup et je vois
bien que le gouvernement a décidé de
mettre en oeuvre un plan mais je doute
que cela suffise et on voit aujourd'hui
que les capacités d'accueil de l'hôpital
public sont sous tension que les
personnels sont sous tension monte le
son des moyens épuisé et par conséquent
c'est une zone d'inquiétude on voit et
fn ont déjà il y a eu des annonces elles
vont prendre un peu de temps à se mettre
à l'honneur
elles sont partielles sont concentrés
sur les hôpitaux de paris pour beaucoup
elle concerne la tête de l'hôpital
public en france mais ce ne sont pas des
moyens humains vous savez ce qui a donné
qui a fait le plus de mal aux pétales
public
je regrette de devoir le rappeler ce
sont les 35 heures qui ont bloqué la
capacité d'action de l'hôpital public
qui lie les riscloises et soit si
peut-être quand on est moyen puise les
personnels le numerus clausus
rappelez vous que le nombre d'étudiants
en médecine a doublé avec jacques chirac
à partir de 2002 on nous raconte que
c'est aujourd'hui qu'ont fait les choses
elles ont été faites mais ça prend très
longtemps pour que enfin mais ça va bien
aller dernier thème de cette émission le
bilan de la loi antiterroriste de 2017
[Musique]
quarante trois jihadistes condamné en
france vont sortir de prison cette année
nicole belloubet l'a annoncé en début de
semaine coïncidence le sénat rendu
public mercredi les conclusions de la
mission de suivi de la loi contre le
terrorisme de 2017
la chambre haute en juge les mesures
efficaces mais propose de renforcer la
surveillance des personnes radicaliser
après leur sortie de prison
fanara caire en 2017
la loi contre le terrorisme avait
transposé dans le droit commun plusieurs
dispositions de l'état d'urgence des
dispositions que le sénat avait alors
assorti d'un caractère temporaire afin
de pouvoir en évaluer la pertinence
c'est désormais chose faite et parmi ces
dispositions
l'une est mise en avant par les
sénateurs les mesures individuelles de
contrôle administratif et de
surveillance dit me casse prononcée par
le ministère de l'intérieur les me casse
permettent aux services de renseignement
de surveiller des individus radicalisés
au delà de leur peine de prison par
exemple via des obligations de pointage
auprès de la police ou de la gendarmerie
aujourd'hui cette surveillance ne peut
excéder une période de 12 mois
trop court selon les sénateurs qui en
appelle à un système plus pérenne que
l'on puisse combler ce vide juridique et
avoir une mesure de sûreté qui concerne
évidemment que les personnes condamnées
pour faits de terrorisme et qui prit sa
avoir suivi judiciaire qui est beaucoup
plus pertinent en terme de durée pour
suivre les personnes mais qui en même
temps protecteur des libertés des
personnes en question les sénateurs
préconisent donc une nouvelle
surveillance judiciaire qui pourrait
aller jusqu'à vingt ans dans certains
cas a sorti également dans volet social
c'est une mesure d'accompagnement post
peine comme il en existe avec une
composante de surveillance c'est vrai
donc ça va être un sujet de fixer les
modalités
le gouvernement nous rejoindra parce que
ses difficultés allaient vraiment
devons-nous à en croire ce sénateur en
marche exécutif et majorité sénatoriale
serait donc sur la même longueur d'onde
sur ce sujet une proposition de loi
devrait bientôt voir le jour au sénat
philippe bas 43 djihadiste français qui
ont purgé leurs peines vont donc sortir
de prison
cette année ça devrait être 60 l'année
prochaine est ce que pour vous ce sont
autant de menaces qui vont être libérés
peut-être pas l'intégralité j'espère
qu'il ya quelques repentis au mois mais
je crois que il ya des raisons de
s'inquiéter
et donc nous disons et c'est urgent
qu'il faut créer une nouvelle mesure
sous le contrôle du juge et que pendant
dix ans quelqu'un qui avait été condamné
qu'à purger sa peine de prison pour un
délit lié au terrorisme voire un crime
lié au terrorisme
d'après lui ce cadre un temps pour un
cri 20 ans pour un crime qui autorise et
bien il y ait une décision du juge
d'application des peines avant la sortie
de prison pour mettre en oeuvre ensuite
on appelle ça un suivi socio-judiciaire
te dire à la fois des mesures de
contrainte et de surveillance mais aussi
des mesures d'accompagnement vers une
réinsertion on essaye quand même le but
ultime c'est quand même de récupérer des
gens pour qu'ils ne deviennent pas
dangereux mais nous considérons que si
leur dangerosité a été constaté à la
sortie de prison par le juge
d'application des peines alors là oui il
faut un contrôle très serré on pourrait
utiliser les mesures qu'on a appelée
mesures individuelles de surveillance
bien sûr même peuvent durer qu'un an et
20 ans c'est très long quand même de
suivi pour une personne radicaliser que
c'est bien sûr que oui
la sndi s'agit par dessus qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'une peine vous le faites
pour les criminels qui ont commis des
crimes sexuels il ya un examen
psychiatrique
on vous dit que l'individu est portée à
la récidive
parce qu'il porte en lui et vous mettez
en oeuvre un suivi très resserré on peut
pas laisser dans la nature des personnes
qui seraient des dangers publics et 20
ans oui bien sûr que oui oui en alliant
oui on peut le faire et on peut le faire
mais j'insiste sur un point qui va vous
paraître peut-être très juridique ça
n'est pas une peine
c'est une mesure pour protéger la
société donc cette nature ne surveillant
dans la condamnation mais cela peut se
prononcer après exactement si c'était
une peine il aurait fallu l'a prononcée
au moment de la condamnation à la peine
de prison
c'est une mesure de surveillance et
aussi de suivi pour l'insertion c'est à
dire que l'on marche sur deux jambes
biba le texte est en cours de
finalisation quand est ce que vous
comptez et le déposer le voir adopté
et est-ce qui va s'appliquer à ces
djihadistes sortie de prison cette année
l'année prochain oui oui c'est notre
objectif et donc nous voulons faire vite
dès la semaine prochaine le texte sera
déposé je crois qu'il fait l'objet vous
l'avez vue d'un large consensus au sénat
la commission des lois du sénat il s'est
exprimé mercredi de la manière la plus
la plus nette est donc à partir du
moment où le texte est déposée je
souhaite que nous puissions l'adopté
très rapidement au sénat est en quelque
sorte nous l'offrons au gouvernement à
l'assemblée nationale pour aller plus
vite
nous sommes les premiers à avoir mis sur
la table les solutions nous pouvons les
discuter alors là vraiment nous n'avons
pas d'amour propre d'auteur mais nous
voulons pour le service de nos
concitoyens pour la sécurité nationale
faire en sorte que ces nouvelles règles
s'appliquent le plus vite nous suivrons
bien sur ce texte et l'évolution de
cette proposition de la merci à vous
philippe bas d'avoir été notre invité
merci dame merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve bien sûr la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
parlement hebdo
[Musique]